ok my name is Latvia yondery i'm founder
of creative society a consulting firm
that impelled a global movement and we
also part of the hub movement so we had
a session yesterday and the session was
called how can we collaborate to create
an ecosystem where social innovation
drive in Europe and Central Asia and I
can say that it was three great
conversation that came up in three great
findings first it was a question how can
we change investors view on instead of
just finding indicators for social
entrepreneurs they can find indicators
on the impact of social entrepreneurs
and build a model from there the second
thing that was quite interesting for
everyone was about how can we relate
together the kapre social responsibility
and also the social entrepreneur and
what great idea came up is that we need
to accept each other as we are and how
can we collaborate together in that
sense and the third one was like how can
you the european funds also like the
policies can support across europe what
is the social entrepreneurship and they
came out with one question is what is
social entrepreneurship so that was what
came up from our session and i hope you
enjoy it thank you